Zach accused her of being in it for the
fame
uh last night if we're real
you went on this show to get famous I
don't know what Zach was on last night
but it was too much for me love is blind
Micah calls out co-stars Zach's Behavior
at the reunion I feel like his comment
was so out of left field I don't even
want to give it the time of day Well
turns out she is giving it the time of
day on the vile files podcast Micah
points out how hard Zack was on their
season four co-star Irina who he was
originally engaged to as he claimed she
was only on the show for the fame but
looking back like I'm sorry you only see
10 of it on the camera there was so much
stuff that happened that was
unbelievable if we're real
you went on this show to get famous
she was sitting there trying to
apologize okay think it's genuine or not
she's sitting there she showed up she's
doing her best and it's just like dig
after dig after dig and then to say
someone's not there for the right
reasons like you've plugged your
Instagram just in this finale or this
reunion four different times I have
receipts but the only receipt I think
the world should see are the ones I
posted on my Instagram today it's like
who's here for fame like you're the one
making all these videos doing all this
stuff she's been on ghost mode for weeks
so I think there's just so much to talk
about that I didn't get to say
everything I wanted to Micah's defense
for Irina may come as a surprise the two
started as besties and got backlash for
being mean girls Mardi Gras
however the ladies had a falling out
after Irina made moves on Micah's former
fiancee Paul after the pods was I the
big fool here that like missed your like
red flags or was it just a
misunderstanding but seems Micah's ready
to forgive and forget yeah we're friends
at first like I took a massive step back
so I was like damn maybe everyone's
right about this chick like what's going
on but I think we both kind of displayed
that we you know immaturity is and I
think if I expect people to believe that
I can like grow and grow up it's like I
should give her that same respect I
think I'm still figuring out who I am
like how can I still be me and still you
know be blunt and open person but kind
of like be careful and cautious of the
people around me because I don't want to
hurt people
thank you